ELEKS — це компанія, яка вже працює на ринку 30 років.
Надає послуги з розробки програмного забезпечення
клієнтам з найрізноманітніших країн.
Цю компанію створила сім’я.
І вони поділилися частинкою своїх сімейних цінностей:
тим, що заробляєш, можна поділитися
і треба поділитися з тими, хто цього потребує найбільше.
Це, напевно, те, що кожному з нас точно підіймає настрій.
Коли ти можеш поділитися, допомогти
і бачиш результат свого вчинку — це дуже класно,
це надихає,
ти розумієш, що живеш недаремно.
Корпоративно соціальна відповідальність — це в жодному
разі не просто виділені кошти.
Ми намагаємося залучити до втілення ідеї людей,
щоб це був якийсь більш внесок.
Ми зробили внутрішній портал, платформу,
де люди подавали ідеї,
інші колеги за них голосували, коментували.
Зараз у нас є три основних напрями:
екологія та здоров’я,
інтелектуальне волонтерство та допомога медичним закладам.
Є ідеї, які не входять в ці три напрями,
але ми нікому не відмовляємо,
намагаємося знайти якісь рішення,
такі, щоб допомогти всім.
Йди сюди. Дай руку.
Бачиш тут? Ти візьми в руки,
візьмись за кінець, приклади оце сюди.
Все, не спіши.
Ручку вперед.
Слухай по слуху.
Не підіймай.
Вона важка, вона важка.
Славік не підіймай, надірвешся.
Достатньо, бо впадеш.
Впаде, впаде, впаде!
Давай ручку, давай.
Де моя подружка?
Все, ходімо!
ELEKS знайшов мене в фейсбуку і запросив виступити
на одній з таких сесій, знаєте,
зустріч з працівниками компанії ELEKS.
І на цій зустрічі я розповідала про те,
що ми робимо для незрячих дітей,
незрячих людей у Львові та в Україні загалом.
Їх це дуже зацікавило.
І ми розпочали вже трошки більше як три роки тому,
ми розпочали нашу співпрацю з створення 3D-макетів.
Ми IT-компанія, й IT-компанія хотіла допомагати тим,
чим не можуть допомогти інші компанії.
Тому ми почали співпрацю саме з друку 3D-моделей,
бо в нас були спеціалісти, 3D-дизайнери
і в нас були спеціалісти,
які могли налаштувати 3D-принтер.
І ми перші моделі друкували повністю самотужки,
розробляли їх повністю самотужки.
Потім, щоб пришвидшити процес,
ми вже залучали інші компанії, невеличкі по Львову,
які нам допомагали це робити
також на благодійній основі.
Один з перших макетів був 3D-макет цирку.
І діти були просто страшенно вражені,
що, уявляєте, цирк круглий.
А далі пішли макети складні:
макети Львівської опери, Латинської катедри,
пам'ятники Івана Франка, Адама
Міцкевича і так далі, і так далі.
Ми до них надрукували супровідні книжки
в універсальному дизайні.
Ми їх друкували ще й англійською мовою.
І так само озвучували двома мовами,
для того, щоб незрячі люди і в Україні, і в Європі,
куди ми возимо ці книжки, могли довідатися
про Львів, про Україну загалом.
І щоб ми могли створити такий, знаєте, гарний імідж,
гарну думку про себе як про країну,
що має такі чудові архітектурні пам’ятки
й ще й дбає про незрячих людей.
Молодь стала тим рушієм змін,
які почалися в результаті Революції гідності.
Напевно, ніхто в 2014 році не очікував настільки великого
соціального руху волонтерства, яке допомогло Україні
бути далі самостійною, незалежною, якою воно є сьогодні.
Напевно, десь воно є в генах українців
вміти об’єднуватись у хвилини такої тривоги.
Воно дуже часто починається з маленького.
В багатьох різних соціальних проєктах
люди додають навіть свій маленький внесок,
декілька гривень.
Якщо, напевно, ви запитаєтесь у своїх людей,
всередині компанії,
хто вже навіть зараз допомагає різним соціальним ініціативам,
то будете, сподіваюсь, приємно здивовані, як були здивовані ми.
Відповідно, коли ви побачите, що всередині є оце бажання, потреба,
вже зрілість людей допомагати ближнім,
все, що вам як компанії залишається, — цьому тільки сприяти.
Більшість наших спеціалістів,
їх вже понад 1800, — українці,
які працюють і у Львові, і в Тернополі,
Івано-Франківську, і в Києві.
І ми отримуємо дуже багато відгуків, що спеціалісти,
яких ми залучаємо і до волонтерської діяльності,
і до втілення інших ідей,
набагато краще відчувають компанію, культуру компанії.
І людям важливо знати, що компанія займається
не лише професійними проєктами,
не лише корпоративним, комерційним розвитком,
а й таким розвитком, як корпоративна соціальна відповідальність.
Була допомога хворим дітям, була допомога будинкам дитини,
різним закладам, які займаються допомогою бідним людям.
Так само була допомога і є на сьогодні — волонтерство,
яке допомагає українській армії,
що веде восьмий рік війну на Сході.
Цього року через те, що тридцятиріччя,
ми собі обрали таку цифру 30, що
ми хочемо зробити 30 добрих справ.
І одна з тих справ — це, саме, аудіодескрипція фільму.
Спочатку обирають фільм,
після цього роблять загалом сценарій,
переглядають, перечитують, що буде по тексту
і оці всі моменти, які людина зряча бачить на екрані.
Наприклад, хтось заходить у кімнату, вимикає світло,
замикає двері — відповідно,
потрібно всі ці моменти втиснути поміж тексту,
який буде звучати у фільмі.
Аудіодескрипція фільму «Теорія всього».
На екрані заставка кінокомпанії «Focus Features» та кінокомпанії «Working title».
Довга розкішна зала, оздоблена фігурною ліпниною.
На стінах розвішені великі картини.
У залі п'ятеро людей: жінка в довгій вечірній сукні
з широким капелюхом на голові,
мужчина у чорному костюмі,
хлопчик і дівчинка підліткового віку
та чоловік у самохідному колісному візку.
Вони поволі рухаються залом.
Напис на екрані — «Теорія всього».
Я Таня, привіт.
Данило.
Яна.
Назар.
Я Таня, дуже приємно.
Давайте ми зараз поп'ємо всі разом чаю,
познайомимось.
Дівчата розкажуть, звідки вони, хто вони,
а потім будемо грати в ігри.
Співпрацю з «Майстернею мрій» ми розпочали
у вересні цього року.
Зараз є два напрями: перший — допомога фінансова, щоб
організувати табір у Карпатах,
і другий — залучаємо колег з ELEKS
для дружніх візитів в організацію,
щоб поспілкуватися з людьми,
якими займається «Майстерня мрій».
Сім, то це вам.
Данило, а ти граєш з нами?
Ну що починаємо?
Яна давай, ти роздавала.
Зараз Данило охайно розкладе кожну карту.
Я свої показувати не буду.
Загалом «Майстерня мрій» займається тим,
що допомагає інтегрувати в суспільство,
допомагає пристосуватися
людям з певними ментальними захворюваннями або ДЦП
до життя в соціумі й того, щоб вони могли вести
такий самий спосіб життя, як будь-яка людина.
Добре, в мене є нуль.
О, супер!
В мене ще є шанс перемогти.
Ти пропускаєш хід?
Хід на тебе вернувся.
Плюс два, плюс два.
Ми як ІТ-компанія, можливо, маємо трохи більше можливостей
і маємо більше ресурсів для того, щоб допомогти
тим верствам населення або тим організаціям,
чи громадським організаціям, які цього потребують.
І дуже тішимося з того,
що ми можемо це зробити та надіємося,
що наші колеги з інших компаній
будуть ще активніше включатися в ці всі процеси.
Я не скажу, що ми ставили якусь певну мету.
Але, напевно, дуже проста мета — щоб люди
навчилися ділитися.
Компанія повинна просто не заважати,
скоріше трохи допомагати
й люди самі придумають, як можна сказати «дякую»,
як можна допомогти оточенню,
як можна зробити щось класне.
Коли цей бізнес може бути прикладом соціально відповідального бізнесу,
таких бізнесів просто ставатиме більше, тому що люди,
які отримали щось, вони так само
колись захочуть цим поділитися.
Відповідно, для мене це знову ж таки
про можливість впливати
на суспільство і ділитися тими цінностями, які маєш.